listen money saving tips is not going to
work when somebody's setting your house and
your community on fire you know what i'm
saying and that is what is happening here
yeah okay so i want to talk about what Martin
Lewis said yesterday Martin Lewis for anyone
who doesn't know is the money saving expert here
in the UK he's got a website he appears on tv a
lot telling people how to save money basically
so a lot of people are reaching out to him now
because millions of people are worried about
the energy prices going up they're already
struggling with the food prices going up they
know that food prices are going to go up more
and they know that the tax rises are going to come
in very soon as well so this is a very serious
situation we've spoken about a lot a lot of
people are really struggling for money right now
so they're reaching out to Martin Lewis the
money saving expert to say you know how
can we cope with this basically so
this guy Martin Lewis he went on
breakfast tv yesterday and he basically said
look all these guys are reaching out to me
and i'm in a situation where i've run out
of things to tell these people basically
like we're reaching the point now where
people are literally going to be losing
thousands of pounds every year and there's there's
no way you can fix that by just optimizing your
personal finances you know you're not going to fix
that by like switching to a new gas provider like
there's no way everything is expensive right um
and the first thing is to say like this shows how
extreme the situation is and the situation is very
extreme but the second thing is this reminds me of
we make a lot of videos right and
very often what comes back from the
videos people send messages saying
what can i do in terms of they know i'm a trader
they're like can i make money from trading
for example or can i make money from investing
just now we filmed a video in the parking here
and some kids came up to us and said oh do you
give advice on personal finance right and totally
understand this i understand this you know i mean
i've been poor myself you see things happening
and you're just like what can i do to protect
myself protect my family to make money right
but the problem is we're in a situation here where
because effectively of government mismanagement
of crisis managing a crisis in such a way that all
the pain goes on poor and ordinary people and the
rich make like a properly a crap ton of money
we've created a situation where increasingly
no matter what you do you can't protect yourself
you know what i mean but we've created a society
where we put the responsibility of protecting
individuals on the individuals meanwhile
the government is doing nothing to protect
individuals and is actively making the situation
of individuals worse but the natural response of
people is to say what can i do for me i understand
that so they contact me and say what can i do for
trading or they go online and they try and trade
bitcoin or they try and get involved in fx trading
or they contact martin lewis and they say you know
what can i do to optimize my finances but the
problem is if everybody is successfully convinced
that what you need to do is focus on your
personal individual situation and at the same
time the government is basically [ __ ] everybody
over we increasingly get in a situation where
people don't fight back and while every single
person is individually trying to save themselves
the government is just screwing everybody it's a
bit like you know and then kung fu films when like
100 bad guys fight bruce lee one at a time that's
basically what we're doing you know like the rich
are taking everything and the only power we have
is there's more of us and we are like individually
one at a time i like well maybe i can change my
electricity provider or maybe i can make money
trading bitcoin you know what i mean but you're
fighting against millionaires and billionaires
here you know what i mean you're not going to
beat these guys these guys want your house they
want your house they want your house they want
your money they want your pension they want your
assets they want you in debt and it's not because
they're evil it's just because they're rich
and they can do it right and you are not going to
fight back by you know changing your electricity
provider you know what i mean or doing these
individual things if you are just a person who
has a net worth of 50 60 grand you can't beat
these guys with a net worth of 50 60 million
but we live in a world where people are being
convinced you have to do you have to take care
of just yourself and you have to compete with
the millionaires and yet people are not uniting
meanwhile the rich and the government are
just screwing everybody you know what i mean
so i think what this made me realize is and i
reached out to martin lewis hopefully it'd be
great if he reaches back people watching send
a message to mike lewis tell him to contact me
we're in a situation here where
unless ordinary people unite
in some meaningful way it's going to be
seriously it's going to be a disaster
and it is happening it's happening now
it's a disaster you know what i'm saying
um and people who've watched it might be seeing me
getting like increasingly like angry in my videos
because you know i've been out here saying for
like more than 10 years now if you don't deal
with inequality it's going to be an economic
disaster for ordinary people and it is you know
unaffordable housing no good jobs you know bad
quality of living unable to afford the basics
and now suddenly we have a crisis that massively
increases inequality and it's going to get worse
um and the only way the only way the only way
we're going to stop this is if ordinary people
poor and ordinary people on mass come together and
demand it because look the chancellor's father-in-law
is a billionaire he's not going to give it to
us right and all of the government they're all
super super rich guys right they're not going to
give it to us and they're funded by even richer
guys they're not going to give it to us we are
only going to improve this if we come together
to push back and yet everybody's just looking for
money-saving tips you know it's not going to work
money-saving tips listen money-saving tips is not
going to work when somebody's setting your house
and your community on fire you know what i'm
saying and that is what is happening here you
know what i mean you know if your country is being
invaded you don't need money saving tips you need
to fight back and that is what is happening here
you know our wealth as a community as a country is
being taken by the super rich and by essentially
a corrupt government to be honest you know if you
have a government that has a crisis enriches the
riches massively takes away food and energy from
the poor raises taxes on ordinary people and cuts
taxes on the super rich with a chancellor who's a
billionaire that is a corrupt government you know
what i mean it's a corrupt government you know
you can talk about corruption in the Russian
government look at our government look at
what they are doing to this country you know what
i mean so yeah i think Martin Lewis is a great guy
you know do what you can to protect yourself
and your family but the fact is this is beyond the
money saving tips and if we do not unite ordinary
people who do not come together as ordinary people
and demand a fairer distribution of wealth
and demand not only that the rich stop getting
richer but that we get something back then
things are going to keep getting worse so um
so yeah i would encourage people watching get
involved support the message and understand
crucially we need to do something about wealth
and equality and that will only be achieved
acting together and acting politically and i'm not
talking about political parties i'm talking about
politics as the exercise of power and our power is
there's more of us and we only use that if we come
together and if we do not come together we lose
and if we lose we see what's happening we lose
our houses we lose the ability to live financially
secure lives and that's what's going to happen um
so yeah people need to come together you
know and i would love them to support
this message and to share it that's all
and if Martin Lewis is watching
send me a message because we need to make
stuff happen, that's it, what else is there to say?
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true